So how would you use learning by correcting mistakes,
to design an agent that can answer Raven's progressive matrices? On one level,
this might seem easy. Your agent is able to check to see if its answers
are correct, so it's aware of when it makes a mistake. But the knowledge of
when it's made a mistake, merely triggers the process of correcting the mistake.
It doesn't correct it itself. So how will your agent isolate its mistake?
What exactly is it isolating here? Once it's isolated the mistake,
how will it explain the mistake? And how will that explanation then be used to
correct its mistake so it doesn't make the same mistake in the future? Now in
this process we can ask ourselves, will your agent correct the mistake itself?,
or will you use the output to correct the mistake in your agent's reasoning?
Will you look at what it did and
say, here's the mistake it made. So next time it shouldn't make that mistake.
If you're the one using your agents reasoning to correct your agent,
then as we've asked before, who's the intelligent one? You? Or your agent?